the full-scale russian invasion of
ukraine not letting up a u.s official
says the russians are moving towards
decapitating ukraine in a multi-step
attack for more let's go to bill hemmer
bill hey jesse good afternoon to you
good evening i want to show you a little
bit on the map behind we're talking a
lot throughout the entire day
as of what's happening with the major
attacks between the ukrainian military
and the russian military uh there's a
big battle up here at chernobyl
apparently the russians have won that
battle there's a battle here northwest
of kyiv the capital city that's still in
dispute it looks like the ukrainians
have pushed back on that in the east
there's a town of kharkiv this is on the
ukrainian side of the border now and
we're getting reports of fierce
ukrainian resistance there as well and
some russian casualties as a result now
jesse on the other side of the border
there's the town of belgorod okay so
this is in russia let me just do
something here we just advance this this
is a satellite image from today
february 24th from a military
uh installation in belgorod all right
and what you can see here is a field
hospital and you've got tents here
denoted off to the left
you have military trucks to the other
side off to the right you've got attack
helicopters many of them up here as well
so this is a staging area for the
russian military in this satellite image
you can see 18 attack helicopters might
be a little hard to show up on screen
there but i can circle them here
and there and here and there as well as
over here and there and on they go so
this is clearly a staging area for the
russian military one more map to show
you right now again this is in this part
of the country where is the russian
military going and how are they going at
ukraine according to a lot of analysts
today and senior defense officials they
describe well this is the belarus border
here in the north and this is the
friendly russian neighbor to the east
remember belarus allowed military
installation to be established on behalf
of the of the russian military
many of them over the past 60 days and
they used those overnight how did they
use them what did they do it's described
as a move here to the northwest of kyiv
and the northeast of kyiv that is one
line of attack the other is toward here
in kharkiv that i just pointed out a
moment ago have not gotten a lot of
reporting from the donbass remember that
was the area taken over in
2014. crimea was the other area and
that's the third area of attack now from
the south into the north and that
appears to be the initial strategy on
behalf of the russian military it is
after midnight now in kiev we'll see
what comes of this very long night for
those people yet again jesse baxter sure
is thank you bill hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else